beyond the reaches of the russian army
refugees from ukraine arrive in the
safety of poland
forced to take only what is most
important only what they can carry
here friendly faces open arms and as
much comfort as can be had sheltering in
a train station
vladimir shamanski was working in the
netherlands when the war broke out he's
waiting for his five sons to arrive from
across the border to take them to safety
he'll then return to ukraine where he
says he will join his wife a soldier in
the national army
ukrainians are prepared to die he says
before ever surrendering their country
to russian president vladimir putin i
can say when ukrainian lose when ukraine
loses europa is can be next one poland
and all europa in maybe
america too so help us or
or it can be the same like ukraine
ukraine's decision to conscript men of
fighting age into the armed forces has
divided families the women who have fled
with their children know that long
goodbyes may turn out to be
final farewells
but there is resilience here my
daughters
always try to have some fun
they can't find fun and
somewhere
everywhere if they have some mama
something toys
but older girl
feel
some they feel that
dangerous situation but we try
to be strong to not so
panic
for many of the displaced the shemesla
train station will be the first time any
of them have seen any sort of help in
days a hot meal a place to rest
rides to cities across europe even
people opening up their own homes to
offer those displaced by the fighting in
ukraine a place to stay
there has been an outpouring of support
from volunteers who want to help any way
they can
we met maria in tears as she searched
for a mother with a newborn she had met
earlier in the day
she came back to the train station with
toys but the mother and baby are gone
i'd gladly bomb putin to england and the
us and other countries just get dozens
of planes to bomb him that's all i want
to say
there is solidarity with ukrainians and
anger at russia
as europe's latest refugees try to
figure out what to do next desperate for
news from the people they left behind
those that made it out of ukraine have a
warning for the rest of the world
millions of lives are at stake help stop
russia while you still can
zain basravi al-jazeera shemeshla
eastern poland